and the spirit award for best male lead
goes to riz ahmed the sound of metal
thank you so much wow thank you to the
spirit awards for this incredible honor
and thank you to the rest of the
nominees for your inspirational work
it's a real privilege to be up here with
all of you guys
uh just a shame not to be able to meet
in person um
independent films where we all learn our
craft is where we grow our crafts where
we can take risks so thank you for this
uh
encouragement uh from the independent
film community
i share this with a lot of people most
of all darius marda i love you man
you're crazy thank you for taking me on
this wild ride thank you for your daring
and your genius
our incredible cast olivia paul shaheem
dominical
lauren uh chelsea just
one honor um incredible crew went the
extra mile every day shout out all the
independent film crews just
going that extra mile our producers at
caviar team at amazon
my own team has got me here especially
kate thank you
um and my family mommy baba bayapa
fatima this is all for you
and i just want to finish by saying that
you know sound of metal is about how a
health crisis can
throw your life off track and on the
other side of that
you know can be a lot of discomfort but
also some clarity and for
everyone who's gone through some
upheaval this year um
i wish you peace on the other side of it
thank you